each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
hi I'm very pleased to introduce Ryan
Pardo who's going to talk to us today
about crowdsourcing audio production
interfaces Brian was my colleague at
Northwestern University he's involved in
both computer science and music and he
has a PhD in one and masters and the
other from University of Michigan he
does a lot of great research on music
and computing and in his spare time he's
a professional musician so thanks for
joining us today thank you ok so I have
just spent the last six months on
sabbatical in London it was awesome but
it it will explain the following three
slides I run the interactive audio lab
at Northwestern University and
northwestern is in chicago and and you
guys being in boston probably need to be
reminded as well since in europe half
the time they're like oh northeastern i
love north no no not northeastern no
North what Seattle I love Seattle no not
Seattle Northwestern University and
beautiful sunny Chicago Illinois ok so
that's one way of locating me another
way of locating me is that I do computer
audition and as she she's rightfully
pointed out it's focused on music a lot
of times if you say computer audition
two people they go oh yeah I know
someone who does speech recognition and
speech recognition is to computer
audition as optical character
recognition is to computer vision a very
important subfield there are others that
we think are important too and so some
of the stuff that that we do is at the
intersection of things like
crowdsourcing music cognition speech
science it's also at the intersection of
machine learning information retrieval
and signal process
somehow or another I have to deal with
all of these things to do what I do and
now I know you're here for the main
event which is talking about the
crowd-sourced audio production stuff but
if anyone's been to the movies lately
you don't actually you paid for the
movie you want to see the movie but you
don't get the movie for the first 15
minutes do you it's trailers for other
movies and in that spirit I'm just going
to tell you a couple of quick things
about other things that we do one thing
that that I worked on is music search
which is solving the problem I have a
song stuck in my head but can't remember
what it's called and hopefully our our
search engine will actually load in your
upgrade and so it would go something
like this I I remember it's a song it's
something like hey dude don't make me
mad find this bad song make me feel
better so maybe I didn't get the lyrics
quite right on that let's see hey more
did it and then okay not going to talk
about that today this is the commercial
in case some of you are meeting with me
later on in the week and in case you
want to talk about one of those things
that's one demo of stuff we do so
information retrieval and by the way
that the database for that search engine
was crowd-sourced if you go to tune Borg
and you sing it a song you will help
increase our search engines ability
another thing I work on is audio source
separation that's where you have a
mixture of sounds that are all together
in a signal and you would like to split
them in two parts that you would like to
work on let's say for example you you
want to do karaoke or maybe something
like speech recognition in a room full
of other noises wouldn't it be great if
you could just have one microphone
record the whole party and then home in
on the the one converse a
that you'd like to listen to wouldn't
that be great for our friends at the NSA
well I prefer to think of the karaoke
application so I'm going to give you an
example or or the deaf people example
hearing aids wouldn't you wouldn't be
great if you could have a clicker that
you could change channels you're trying
to listen at a party just listen to the
person you want to listen to here's
here's a quick example of one kind of
source separation that we've been doing
so here's the original piece of audio
maybe I wanted to do a karaoke version
where I play my clarinet instead of them
playing their clarinet and so we just
did a little source separation and then
I can play my part over that again is
not the focus of this talk but if you
want to talk to me about how we do that
I would love to know what I'm here to
talk about is the following problem I am
in fact someone who makes music and that
music you heard was me and if you
couldn't tell that was something that
sort of old-time easy now the problem is
it actually sounds too good modern
recording stuff that you get sounds
great I want it to sound more like this
like it's being played of over little
transistor radio or off of an old record
instead of like that
now I know what you're going to say well
okay so play it off of a little
transistor radio problem solved but I am
a technologist and I make technology and
and my first thought is to use all the
high-tech tools at my disposal so I go
to the audio equivalent of Photoshop
which is called Pro Tools and this is
pro tools and what you see here is a
typical Pro Tools session sort of
mid-session and displayed on here is a
tool that will achieve this for me if
only I pick the right one is anyone here
confident that they know which tool that
is raise your hand if you are ok I'll
help you out now it might be a little
more obvious let's blow that guy up this
is a parametric equalizer parametric
equalizers allow you to boost or lower
different frequency components of audio
so you if you want to boost what you
think of as the low end you turn one of
these knobs you boost the mid-range or
the high end you turn a different knob
here we go this is a typical tool
included with a typical you know
industry standard audio suite and the
first thing I think to myself is where's
the tinny knob right and of course there
isn't one and most people I talk to are
not actually audio people their visual
people and you've experienced this with
Pro Tools right you have an idea in your
head you've got a clear idea of what you
want to make the problem is that's the
interface you've been handed and it is
not so clear even if someone tells you
the right tool what on earth do I do
with this to get the effect I'm looking
for right not clear so one thing you do
is you spend six months learning how to
work pro tools but one thing I would
like to have happen is instead of you
learning what the software means by
parametric Equalization I want the
software to learn what you mean by tinny
so wouldn't it be great if instead I go
it's too tinny or it's not teeny enough
and it says well here's a tinny knob
let's let's deal with that
well of course this brings up the issue
of how do we get the machine to
understand what i mean when i say tinny
it is not helpful to look up in a
dictionary the definition for tinny
because that is not what you say it how
you say it is not anything actionable by
a machine its it'll say teeny you know
metallic and that doesn't tell us what
frequency components to raise or lower
what to do so what we do instead is we
play a sound for you and we say okay you
want I don't know what tinny means
here's a sound now I'm going to change
different frequency components from the
low to the high end and if you see
something raised it means that frequency
had its volume boosted and if it's below
the line that means it was cut well how
teeny is that you want to give me a
rating about this
or that essentially it's dealing with
you the way you know maybe your
four-year-old child deals with you is
that a dog yes that's a dog is that a
dog know that that's a that's a cat and
then they show you like a Snoopy cartoon
is that a dog well sort of it's a dog I
mean it's a cartoon of it stop asking so
many questions right but that's the only
way you really learn a definition you've
got to you have to provide instances ask
how dog like this is or in this case how
tiny it is and get some sort of idea of
from your teacher of how close that is
to the mark of this concept we're trying
to learn and so what we're going to be
doing here is we're going to be talking
about machines that learn audio
descriptors adjectives for describing
sound qualities and the only way they
can really do that really is to play a
sound and learn from you what you think
of that sound in light of this
descriptor now we've already done this
and in fact made and equalizer plug-in
that you can already download this is
the student that first worked with me on
this has since graduated and started a
startup company and he made this
equalizer called IQ and I don't know how
clear it is but here it says dislike and
here it says like before we got on to
the labeling words we just wanted to get
at the sound quality without worrying
about the word label and so it plays
audio for you and when you hear a sound
you uh you drag the sound is associated
with a little puck here that you dragged
back and forth to say oh that sounds
pretty good that doesn't sound pretty
good and each puck is associated with a
different equalization a different
mixing up of the sound to try and find
out what qualities it is that influenced
you in your decision about what you
think of it and
what you end up with is you gained up
with some kind of a controller I was
just teaching this
where you make it more or less teeny
based on something you just learned and
yeah we'll come back to that later now
so so how this works let me let me first
describe to you what this all is this is
a representation of the amount that
somebody is boosting or cutting
something I believe this was for the
word warm somebody was teaching it their
concept for warm a different frequencies
here's 125 hertz that's no and then
here's like and higher than i can
whistle okay so this is frequency and
this is how much we boost or cut a
frequency and this is the learned amount
to boost or cut in order to grab a
certain person's concept now how did we
decide how much to boost or cut well we
asked them lots of questions we
literally provided different EQ curves
like i said before back here all these
different EQ curves and we said how much
do you like that and you give an answer
oh I like this one a lot this one's
pretty tinny okay great if you think of
each of the 40 bands this is a 40 band
equalization each of the 40 channels as
an independent thing now we can discuss
offline whether or not that's a good
assumption but let's pretend for the
moment that it is each of the 40
channels then gets an amount we boosted
it and what you thought of it so a
negative point eight plus up 15 DB or
125 hertz a negative point eight plus
down by about 15 DB for maybe around a
thousand Hertz okay these are
two-dimensional points that we can put
in a scatterplot the game that we
applied in any particular example and
the rating the person gave that exam so
if we treat each frequency as its own
independent thing suddenly if I've rated
30 or so examples I can produce a
scatter plot here and start to see a
main effect for how much
boosting or cutting that frequency
seemed to affect how much you thought it
was for example in this case warm and so
if you do a simple linear regression
this is this is the first approach we've
done we've tried smarter around knots
market we tried more complicated things
since which aren't necessarily better if
you get a positive slope the amount of
your so the angle of your slope tells us
how much boosting seems to boost your
liking of it if you've got a negative
slope that tells us how much reducing
the amplitude at that frequency seems to
increase your liking of the example and
if you've got essentially nothing then
we neither boost nor cut it's a very
straightforward thing and that goes
ahead and makes this IQ equalizer and I
said it's been released it's been
released and reviewed and downloaded and
this is a nice thing it does something I
haven't seen before simply and well it
could help bridge the language gap
between musicians and engineers in a non
combative way one of the things that
happens to musicians and engineers is
they do speak different languages and
the musician will come in and I was
actually in a recording session where
the violinist said ah I don't have the
sheen on my violin town that I'm looking
forward can you give it more of a sheen
and the engineer said show me the sheen
knob and I will turn it and of course
there was no Sheen knob and this would
be a thing where the engineer could now
say you know what why don't you just try
IQ and I'll come back in a few minutes
and we'll see what we've got we've had
users try the this in the lab and we've
asked them to teach it a set of words
and then what we did was we said okay
teach it a word and then we'll hand you
a controller and you play with the
controller and then you tell us how
satisfied you are that it learned the
concept you were after and their ratings
were between learned concept these were
things provided to them they the their
rating labels were learned concept
perfectly did not learn
learned the opposite concept and 35
people on these variety of words they
seem to be learning because we were in
the Midwest and Midwest owners are
polite and they want you to feel good
every time we did this we gave them a
randomly ordered pair one was the
controller that actually was learned on
their data another was a controller
learned on random responses machine
generated and this is the random
response one you can see there's an
actual bias here of positivity on the
part of Midwesterners I don't know I've
never done the experiment on the East
Coast I will say that my Midwestern bias
I'm from the Midwest I teach in the
Midwest I work in the Midwest I would
expect this number to drop a little
because you guys are a little more tell
it like it is it was a mix of musicians
and non-musicians drawn from basically
three populations you can already guess
computer scientists in people the the
student was working with me with this
was in the speech and hearing science
department so speech pathology students
so people with pretty good ears and
musicians and it was about a third of
each we for this we did we're going to
move forward to ones where we did not
supply the terms the reason we were
supplying the terms was because we
wanted to have enough people all do the
same thing so we could actually talk
about it for a particular word are we
getting satisfaction from a large number
of people so we had to force them to
pick words we literally occupied a
computer lab and had a pizza party and
got 35 people to show up and just did it
that day then from that we went ahead
and said okay what if we were to put
this in a 2d space we did a little
principal component analysis and now
each one of these is what I call a user
concept that is a word taught to the
machine by one person in one set
training session and we've color-coded
them muffled as green tinius blue bright
as yellow warm is red
broad is black and we tried to find like
some some orientation that seemed good
to sort of show us some stuff and one of
the things that we were learning from
this is that the distribution for
example of teeny and bright they kind of
overlap each other in this set of people
and then teeny actually overlaps with
muffled and bright but bright muffled
tend not to overlap with each other and
so we did some work on this and we
published a paper about it with a with
kind of a new interface that we were
proposing for some commonly used words
why don't we have an equalizer that is
in terms of these words that we've been
learning from a small group of people
and you just drag a dot over the word
you want and it gives you that audio
effect now how many people here are
researchers who publish papers and
conferences could you just raise your
hand keep your hand up if anyone in
industry has ever just read one of your
papers and decided to make a thing yeah
okay this is my one right literally a
guy read this paper from the company
tone boosters and he came up to me and
he said hey um I made this is that okay
and I was so excited of course yes just
just link back to our website so they
did and um and this is a commercial
thing that this one's free actually it's
with a it's one of those shareware you
know pay-what-you-want kind of things
and so people generally don't pay but
but what but we're getting here is that
we actually published the paper someone
read it and made it and made a
commercial commercially available or a
broadly available product and it's
downloadable and that's great so here's
an example of using that
now just as a reminder how long do you
think it would take you to do that with
this interface even if you know how to
work it ah so this thing was released
into the wild and started to get
reviewed by real users on the website
gear which it is the name it is it
is for audio equipment gear heads I
don't know but but these are people who
know how to work equalizers and who are
the kind of person who already knows the
complicated interface and we were
getting some really cool things like the
easy Q is what it was called is really
really cool can't believe I tried it on
an already good mix and it made it
clearer and punchier so it was really
nice to hear from the people who
actually use the complicated products
that these simpler interfaces that we're
working on are actually helping is one
of the pieces of blowback that I've
gotten more than once is you know we
submit this stuff to a conference which
is full of the people who have spent all
that time learning the complicated
interface and part of their ego is tied
up in having this high priesthood
knowledge that the masses don't have and
they don't want to hear that we're going
to hand this ability to people who
haven't gone through the hazing ritual
of learning these interfaces so it's
nice to hear from those in the wild that
that they like it well I think in terms
of music and audio generally Andy the
graduate student working with me thinks
in terms of well he was getting his PhD
in speech and hearing science and so he
said you know I thought of another user
population that might like to have
something to change the audio quality of
sound
who really really really don't want to
know how it works they just want it to
work and that is hearing aid users
because it turns out hearing aids are
essentially while they're multiband
compressors these days and for the
uninitiated let's just say that's a
fancy kind of equalizer and for the
initiated I'm sorry for having made that
terrible oversimplification but could
you do something like this with a
multiband compressor with hearing aids
and a first step has already happened I
mentioned Andy started this company your
machine and with this interface the one
that we just showed you the dark teeny
bright warm and is working hard to
commercialize fancier versions of it so
these interfaces that we started out
talking about how to do this for
musicians for people who produce audio
which is really a small segment of the
population it turns out upon reflection
there are other people in the world that
have problems with these things and
those people are far more common and and
we are going to help them now one thing
that you might say about this is well
what if the sound I'm looking for isn't
one of these four things what then well
you go back to the original interface
the one with the questions where we say
well is this is that what do you think
of this it will get to it but it takes
some time and so that turns out to be a
little bit of an issue because not
everyone wants to play 20 questions or
perhaps 30 questions what this is is the
number of audio examples someone has to
rate and this measure is the machine
tries to guess what you'll say about the
next audio example it selects so it
tries to figure out it's learning a
model of you as you're going and it says
okay this next one I bet I bet Nichole
is really going to like this one and
then if it's wrong it's oh ok so my
ability to predict you wasn't as good as
I thought and so right now with this
thing that I described a kind of
asymptotes in its ability to correctly
predict your rating and about like this
or
on point seven something I haven't shown
you is that when we done the clinical
trials on on people in the lab setting
it turns out if we repeat examples for
you so let's say in the actual early
experiments we would give you 75
examples you have to listen to the catch
being that or sometimes more but the
catch being that a large portion of them
would be repeats to see whether you were
consistent in your responses and it
turns out people generally tend to have
about a point 7 consistency that is to
say if we did a Pearson's correlation on
pairwise we gave you the example than 14
examples later we gave it to you again
and what did you rate it as their it
gets to predict you about as well as
knowing what you answered the question
last time we'll do in terms of predicted
we are describing the interface that
existed before you have here we are on
our website version of this each us a
word
what happens now it plays a sound you do
this and this is how it's working and so
if you change your mind about this in
light of further examples you're free to
move it so yet that question actually
came up and this was the solution that
we came up with you can argue about this
solution as well for example the
vertical dimension is meaningless on
that thing that you just saw and maybe
we should have some meaning for it okay
so what we've talked about is how can I
knowing nothing learn the meaning of an
adjective that describes sound like that
an equalizer could manipulate then we
talked about well I having a vocabulary
of four words could I give you an
interface that's better than the
interface you're used to seeing um well
I just noticed that the colors in my
anyway um now what we want to do is move
beyond that and we would like to be able
to free it up and have you use whatever
words you want but not have to ask you
30 questions to figure out what that
means and one thing that we can do to
make that happen is transfer learning
remembering what we were taught by
someone else before so these are
equalization curves that two different
users produced four different different
words and so here we go bright tinny
both from user one here's bright from
user two and one thing that I'll just
mention is that these two just
qualitatively looking at them look more
like each other than these two even
though these two share a label okay so
one person thinks of this EQ setting
that you would see here as pini probably
they don't like it the other person is
like well it's not bad it's bright it's
not bad and so we start to see a thing
here where we have a distribution and we
saw that in the when we do
displayed the individual user concepts
in that 2d space we don't exactly tend
to agree on the definition of any words
right what does love mean to you we have
kind of a distribution of meaning and so
how do we deal with that distribution of
meaning when we're trying to have
something interact with us okay how can
we use this person's prior data to help
us learn this and maybe we can't do the
simplistic thing that you think of first
and say just hand them that person's
right because maybe that's not as good
as this so what we do is the following
you have some sound we manipulate it
with different equalization curves a
variety of people have rated them in
light of the word that they were trying
to teach it okay so here we have soo
teaching it warm Jim teaching it dark
and Bob teaching it fat each person goes
ahead and rape the examples and now what
we've got is an interesting thing here
we've got one example that's been rated
by various people for various purposes
what good is that well we're going to
talk about that in a minute what if
since I've only got a two-dimensional
display surface here what I'm going to
do is I'm going to talk about everything
in sort of a 2d world that you can
imagine a higher dimensional world I
hope so let's take somebody's concept
Sue's idea of what warm me I'm going to
take two examples that she's rated
here's example to an example 3 and she
gave it a point 8 and negative point 5
and we're going to take her concept warm
and put it into in this case a 2d space
whose coordinates are determined by what
people rated various examples
so this is your rating of example to
this is your rating of example 3 for
that content here we've got Sue's warm
Jim's dark and Bob's fat how is this
going to help me let us say that I have
a new concept it could be anything
Brian's needles that means fearful in
one translation but we'll see it might
not always mean fearful in English so
I've got some new concept here well how
do I put myself in that my concept in
that space well it's simple I asked
Brian to rate the two examples that
everyone else is already rated and given
my responses we put me in that space now
now we can figure out how much our
knowledge of what other people have
taught it can influence this new concept
it turns out even though none of these
words matched the new word I just came
up with one of them is a lot closer in
terms of how someone responded to the
questions we were asking so you know if
we put this in political terms do you
want to call yourself a progressive or a
liberal well probably in the US people
who call themselves one of the other
will answer questions about whether they
want health care to be paid for by the
government in a similar way and so even
though they've got different labels you
might be able to place them close to
each other in a space in the political
spectrum so here's the same idea even
though we've got different labels I can
figure out how much influence my
knowledge learned from prior examples
should influence my learning for the new
example okay so then the question is
which questions to ask well you want to
ask a divisive question
if we take a look at the variance in
people's responses to the different
examples played to them one of these
examples didn't show nearly as much
variance as another and this would be
you know a question of let's say again
I'm just using this political example if
the question that I put on my
questionnaire was what's your favorite
flavor of ice cream chocolate or vanilla
I'm guessing I haven't done the research
but I'm guessing that it will probably
be less correlated with political party
than if I said who's a better president
barack obama or Ronald Reagan one of
these things will bifurcate our groups
in a way that we're looking for and the
other one probably won't hear what we're
doing to figure out which examples to
play 1st they put us in that coordinate
space or figure out which ones separate
different peoples concepts this is a
kind of active learning so the active
learning is driving our transfer
learning because what we're doing is
we're figuring out what questions are
good questions to ask too quickly home
in without bothering the user too much
on if I can just ask a couple of
questions let me just ask this do you
like chocolate ice cream and Barack
Obama or D like you know in this case do
you like this sound or that sound and
from this we get our placement in the
space so what so this is our baseline
learning again the ability to predict
what you'll say to the next example I
play you how much you like it here it is
with transfer learning when we can when
we actually have examples of the same
word in our database here it is when we
have no examples of the same word in our
database and this is on a logarithmic
scale so you have to pay attention to
that so actually if we start out you
haven't answered any questions if if we
just have to guess the average of other
other other sounds we're going to do
kind of badly if we can make that
average other sounds with the same label
we do much better but we still do better
than
just the baseline even in this case
where we don't have the same label okay
so what's that idea again instead of
asking you to rate 30 examples to learn
a word we're going to ask you for maybe
three ish we're going to use those
ratings to locate your concept relative
to known concepts and then we're going
to augment training by using the ratings
from these already rated stuff weighted
by distance now the first thing that how
many people here know what collaborative
filtering is yeah so many people will go
oh okay so it's like collaborative
filtering you hand me the nearest word
or whatever and this is not exactly
collaborative filtering because we do
not use prior user data to pick an
existing object for you we use it in
conjunction with your responses to build
a new semi personalized thing so a new
user concept is still placed in the
space and it's weighted by excuse me
it's a combination of your responses and
other people's past responses to things
weighted by distance and the more
questions you feel like answering the
more we can home in on you the less you
feel like answering the more it's going
to be a general well other people who
like bright sounds kind of went for this
so the goal here is to build a
personalized controller tool that by
asking you as few as three questions
boom will give you the thing you need to
manipulate the sound whether that be in
my case thinking of a musician like an
acoustic musician who doesn't want to
learn pro tools but just wants to make
make that the sound of their vocals
brighter whatever brighter means well
that's an interesting question the thing
is most people you've asked like this
deep philosophical question I want it to
be brighter for other people most people
kind of figure well if it looks right to
me it's bright
because they obviously have no way of
doing once if you want to do that for a
large audience then you kind of have to
start doing samples of other people and
the kind of people I tend to work with
as musicians don't have the kind of
money to bring in focus groups yes and
we're going to move forward towards
something like that not quite there you
already saw that we've got something up
on the web right now that asks you to
teach us a word now mind you right now
what's on the web is the full out
experimental version which you'll have
to answer 40 questions because we're
doing repeats and we're trying to get
lots of baseline data why let's come
back to this idea instead of 13 ratings
30 ratings asked for three use responses
from data for prior concepts well first
you have to have a database of prior
concepts if I don't have a big old
database of words taught to me by
hundreds or thousands of people this
thing won't fly because probably when
you enter a word it's like I want it to
sound more fat no one will have taught
at that we're back to the base case of
having to ask you well as this fat is
that fat so what's on the web right now
is socially q org where we ask you out
of the goodness of your heart to help us
learn the meanings of adjectives that
describe sound and one of the things
I've discovered is people are
good-hearted I learned this with our
music search engine where we are we've
asked people to fill our database with
songs the thing is though people are
good-hearted when it's not a lot of work
so sing it's much more fun to sing a
song so when you teach tune bought a
song you go in you click I'm teaching it
this song and then you sing Hey Jude or
whatever it is you saying and you're
done this takes a little time maybe 10
minutes
generally the average person who clicks
on to something on the on the web 10
minutes is a lifetime so we do not get a
lot of people as we'd hoped for the full
experimenting so we did what all people
do when our idea of a fun activity on
the web that you're going to love and
just give us data doesn't give us as
much data as we'd hoped for we turn to
bribing people in a micro task market
that some people have probably heard of
called Mechanical Turk this is a thing
where people who are bored and need a
little bit of money go on and find short
jobs on the order of 10 minutes to get
paid very small amounts of money to do
the job and so we posted sorry uh I
guess it depends where they're living so
the question was do I pay them a living
wage and depends how you live you'll see
what I pay them in just a moment so we
have we can no longer get people from
India Mechanical Turk does not allow
people to sign up we're not based in the
United States as I discovered when I was
on sabbatical and trying to test our
software from London they wouldn't let
me use it so had to get around that but
anyway um teach us a word has been
posted on Mechanical Turk and so has
teach us a word in Spanish people are
paid a dollar to teach it a word so if
it takes you 10 minutes then you're
getting about six bucks an hour you can
decide for yourself if you think that
would be a living wage and as I just
mentioned there's 40 rated examples for
per word and 15 of these are repeats so
that we can measure your consistency so
once we get your data we have some
inclusion criteria for the data and the
first one is did you teach us a word
that's in a dictionary so unfortunately
that fat phad wouldn't make this
inclusion criterion and would be bounced
although we can expand that with slang
dictionaries urban dictionary we haven't
done that to date we still keep the data
but for the stuff i'm going to show you
things that are you know
the number eight in it or anything like
that gets gets bounced we also asked
them are you listening on good speakers
in a quiet room not everyone is we are
not going to show you that data because
if you're listening for sound quality if
someone is listening in a noisy room on
on speakers that are tending to begin
with like their laptop speakers their
ability to distinguish we've already
done this study we know they can't tell
so we get rid of those we also get rid
of people who took longer than one herb
know who took less than one minute to
complete the task because generally
those are the people there's always
someone on Mechanical Turk who's trying
to go pay me and so we need to do
various things to deal with that and one
is it just take your time and I
mentioned consistency we're not any data
that I'm going to display for you is
going to be data where they showed a
consistency they repeated their response
and the consistency was at least within
one standard deviation of the mean so it
could be more but if you got below one
standard deviation below what the
average person was doing in terms of
consistency this was more evidence that
perhaps you didn't really tell us the
truth about whether you were listening
in a quiet room or you weren't really
trying even if you took longer so as of
Tuesday which is yesterday we've had
fourteen hundred and thirty-five
training sessions out of which slightly
over a thousand have have fit our
criteria and of these training sessions
758 turned out to have a word that was
in the English dictionary 314 had a word
that was in the Spanish dictionary these
represent this many distinct words and
of course this means on average there's
about three people teaching it the same
word in Spanish and about two ish in
English this is obviously not evenly
distributed it looks like it's following
something like zips law and this is how
many people have contributed so far
you are of course busy hot well paid
researchers with many other things to do
but if you would like to go on to
mechanical turk and help us with this we
would be grateful and you could earn a
dollar actually if you're really
consistent we even give you a bonus so
ok so here's a display of a portion of
the space and I just I kind of just
picked a part of it that looked pleasing
to me somehow pleasing and these are
words and the idea here is that the size
of the word indicates how much agreement
there was across multiple individuals
who happen to have taught us that word
so sometimes if you've got a small word
like this all that really means is that
it's only been taught to us by one
person if you've got a nice big word
that means more than one person has
taught us and those people tend to do
agree in the in the final definition of
what that that word was so this is just
kind of a visualization just for you to
see the kinds of words that are that are
appearing we haven't that you asked
before did we select the words we did in
the clinical trial in this one it's just
you pick the word you teach us anything
you want because we want to find out
what words people would tend to choose
and we want to find out which ones tend
to be manipulate all that we're
providing them so there it is in Spanish
again this is you can see here this is
called model it's just a portion of the
space that I for some reason decided
looked attractive to me and so I grabbed
it and you can see the kinds of words
here that we're getting and you know
some of them like beyond oh now that's
an interesting one right because one of
the audio samples we provide is a piano
but for those of you who know what piano
means the pianoforte means the soft loud
so I'm not sure what they're getting out
with this one honestly and yeah so
ospital feel thank you though
interesting so let's I talked about the
word teeny before this is just kind of
again
here they are put in it we did
multi-dimensional scaling and threw them
into a 2d display for you even though I
mean there's there is some relation to
how close things are from this but it's
there in a higher dimensional space and
it's not always as simple as that well
let's look at some stuff one of the
things we decided to do for for this
instead of just giving you a straight
line like we did for a particular
individual what we've got here are
distributions where the brighter it is
the more likely it is someone was would
say that you should set the EQ about
like this at this frequency so what we
see here here's the word tinny eight
people have taught us tinny on our web
version and there's this sort of broad
cut the low frequencies boost it up
around a thousand Hertz maybe another
boost around seven or eight thousand you
can see sort of a secondary kind of hump
happening here and these are actually
distributions we're showing you like
slices of vertical distributions of the
their parameterised distribution so we
can get into the details but I just want
you to sort of see one here's another
word light and for light I'm getting
this upward feeling right now coming
from you're visually dominated
linguistic paradigm would someone here
like to give me what the opposite of
light is dark and this is the thing that
we're finding for hard now before we did
it like before yesterday I didn't even
realize hard was a word that people were
using to describe eq I literally you
know I work in this area I had no idea
but we're getting a pretty good kind of
angled thing here like this and so now
imagine you're an audiologist
right and this person with a hearing aid
comes to you and they say yeah so the
hearing aid is sounding really hard I
wouldn't even know where to begin well
now I might because I could go to our
tool here and say what's what's a hard
sound and they might be saying oh look
it's really boosted in the low ends and
the low frequencies it's really loud in
the high frequencies it's cutting off
okay okay does anyone here speak Spanish
I know you all speak English great what
is a Spanish if you were going to
translate the word chunky we haven't
gotten we've only gotten two people
teaching us see each of these we're not
sure yet I mean it's it's provocative
it's not you know once we've got maybe
ten people teaching us each of these
words I'll feel more confident in saying
this but here's the curve we learned for
chunky which by the way it's really
shocks me that chunky showed such strong
agreement across the even the two people
that did this and here we have both then
thing in a million years I never would
have guessed first of all that chunky is
a word people are using to describe
sound and using in a way that is
reproducible and understandable by
another person and to that the
translation but then thiz just what you
think strong potent that in Spanish I
might want to use that word
well no like chunky you know what chunky
I'm a little chunky chunk another way
say chunky but did you know this one
yeah me neither I don't know hard to
lift so the high end is low I I don't
know but one of the things we're
discovering is that if you look in
dictionary definitions they usually are
dealing with the dominant visual
paradigm sometimes we touch like soft I
would have expected soft might be the
opposite of hard but in audio of course
we know it's soft and loud and so when
you look at dictionary definitions for
words a lot of times what you're going
to get is something that's dominated by
a different modality so this opens up a
possibility of translation through
perception you compare the learned
equalization curves find in another
language the word whose matched to an EQ
curve that is most similar to the one
that you found in your home language and
there you go and now the thing is these
translations are different from those
derived from the paired text why is
there a letter be there and you know I
know I'm being videoed well here we go
it just it's nagging at me saving
alright gotta restart it they're
different from those derived from paired
text and I think they might be better
for audio description and so just as
sort of a taking a look at that I picked
some words here in Spanish I gave you
here these are according to a certain
criterion of which what's close close
words in English according to social eq
as based on measuring how similar their
eq curves are here are the words that
Google Translate listed as common
translations as opposed to other labels
that give it like uncommon and rare and
just have a look now for this one sharp
penetrating acute shrill these are all
good definitions in fact Google has this
an uncommon translation shrill which is
actually the top translation for our
thing which makes sense because our
thing is focused entirely on sound and
sharp and penetrating these are you know
might be like sharp pain and acute pain
they're looking at other modalities and
audio sharp isn't there I'm sorry shrill
is in there but i think it's like number
seven suave as Enrico so here we get
soothing calm peaceful soft and here
we've got some nice agreement soft
gentle sweet here's our both dente too
chunky the one that you just looked at
where powerful and potent are the Google
translations which are the ones i would
have said a weird one that I didn't
realize her Spanish just like I didn't
realize chunky was a word miedoso
fearful now I don't know about this
translation funky but okay but Mia also
pretty strongly correlates to crisp
light and bright I would have never
guessed that
so I think this this is kind of an
interesting thing so we're collecting
hundreds and hopefully we're going to
get to thousands of words that have been
contributed by thousands of people on
the web and we're learning what these
adjectives mean in terms of real
actionable changes to the audio that we
can use to provide you tools like a
language-based hearing aid interface I'm
finding the sound in here too hard can
you help me hearing aid or can you help
me audiologist and the audiologist says
hang on let me just look up what you
might mean by that yeah I gave you an
example of that or like as a musician
the music sounds chunky how can I fix
that and the tool says try the D chunk
knob perceptually grounded sound
adjective dictionary translation tool I
already talked about that you know
you've got that person that comes in
who's a primarily a Spanish speaker
you've got a really good Spanish
speaking but not native audiologist
who's like hmm the only meaning i know
for that sound miedoso the patient says
the hearing aid sounds fearful what on
earth does that mean well according to
the social eq database it turns out
there's some synonyms for that which
include crisp and bright that's
something as an audiologist even work
with ok so the punch line here is we're
not rethinking sound interfaces we're
rethinking the interface or we're
teaching the interfaces to rethink
themselves they learn from you they
provide new tools based on what they
learn from you and ideally allow you to
do things that you couldn't have done
otherwise I say we those of you who work
in academia know that professors tend to
use the Royal we
there's always people in the background
doing heavy lifting that the professor
is ideally avoiding mark heart right
David little Zafar rafi and Andy Saban
have all done great things to contribute
to this whole project as we've moved
along and of course the NSF is funding
it so we have to thank them for all the
great stuff they've done there that's
the talk I guess this is the point where
I'd ask if there are any any questions
yes okay for the recording should they
be talking on to a microphone should she
say that again oh okay the musical
scores I was actually a music by Brandon
MTV years Wow cool it was hard dress was
to talk to different groups of people
about um genre and I was thinking about
city of lights away something about that
on the one hand that difficulty of
translation and on the other hand the
difficulty or those sort of temptation
to use algorithms to me t like they're
not my punk rock and your idea of riot
girl where that fits in it's sort of
like old is outsourced it's the
algorithm they're just curious if you
had any like interests in rivet that was
the thing that you're thinking about a
sort of like associating a sound with a
genre like I can imagine that sort of
being this like objective idea of like
well enough people say that you know oh
whatever um you know dubstep is funky
and it's also tinny um and so this track
is like that and therefore it's dubstep
and so i don't have to intervene with
that but I hate dubstep and I don't it
well I'll answer that in a couple ways I
don't work on that because there are so
many people already working on that if
you go to
the Izmir is mi r dot net is Mir net
there's a conference international
society of music information retrieval
who one of their main themes is
automatic sonra recognition and there
are annual competitions on automatic
genre recognition and a lot of them have
that same initial starting point of well
let's just get it from the low level
basic sound and you can do that to a
degree but as you're already aware what
happens in one second or even ten
seconds might not be enough if you don't
pay attention to other things for
example what makes something a waltz
well it's in three-four time what makes
it a blues oh well it has a blues chord
progression and it's played by muddy
waters what makes something a murder
ballad while the lyrics have to be about
murder so there's there's some John Roos
can be easily distinguished from each
other in terms of this low-level audio
stuff like it's very easy to tell heavy
metal from string quartet but then if
you said okay waltz are not waltz well
in fact a heavy metal song could be in 3
4 and a string quartet could be playing
something in 34 and you have to listen
to something longer and learn things
about beats and stuff so there's a lot
in there but the Izmir conference is
where you want to look and and a lot of
people are interested
that I got it and he wanted to recreate
sounded couldn't uh-huh the tools that
he had it was it was just a really close
study of sort of the cultural
innovations that happened around the
efforts in the Cuban dance to try to
replicate this sound and like I say I
don't know where that goes in terms of
the question but I'm kind of imagining
this world will people go it's not a
problem they just play Skrillex and says
oh you need to do this with until you've
got right and on the one hand that's
incredibly cool you feel something gets
lost their I guess I'd like to hear your
thoughts on innovation and invention and
creativity and I guess in a way that
goes to sort of what justice getting at
to of what is I can see the incredible
utility of what you're going back I
don't in any way mean to undermine it
but I'm I can also see the engineers
reaction that's sort of wait a minute
this is an art and we have so much I've
got 30 years of being in this gym
knowing what a singer means when he says
I want my voice to be dry and I know how
to get dry in our what not her so what
does happen to that innovation does this
free people have to do more innovations
of other kind of it how do you view what
you do relative to okay i will give you
three answers to that because this is a
question that's come up before the first
one is i'm going to i'm going to give
the hard the march of progress doesn't
cease for anyone answer which is if you
think about it what I want to do when
I'm cooking a meal is heat the food to a
certain agree to achieve certain effects
of denaturing things in bloody blonde so
I have a beautiful fried egg there there
is an art to fire starting there is a
fart on art to kindling there is an art
to doing all of these things that it
took to make a fire and there there were
people who are very good at it but what
happens is you're good at a particular
level of technology a level of tool and
and you the culture explores that
and then eventually someone comes up
with a tool that allows you to bypass
that step such as the gas oven or many
other things the lighter there's no
there's nothing keeping us from going
back to flint right now but people
generally prefer lighters because it
turns out the thing they care about is
not the art of fire starting so that's
the kind of like really pushy your
technology is going going away answer
but another another answer is there is
nothing keeping you from using the
existing set of tools they're there we
are adding to your palate sometimes it
will be meaningful and useful to use
something in the same way that a
calculator is meaningful and useful to
use but I already know what six times
seven is it's 42 I don't need a machine
to tell me that I learned my
multiplication tables when I see these
kids today using a calculator to tell
them that really come on the culture
moves forward and certain people decide
to rely on that tool for something and
free up that brain space to do another
thing that's answered too and I'm going
to am I going to be like rick perry and
forget what the third answer was I think
answer three is the following and
something we haven't yet done in the
project I want to do education so if you
right now coming back to this let's say
that someone says to me I want to make
it light and I'm and I'm thinking I
don't know what that means and it shows
me this and now I can go to a certain
tool and be like okay I'm going to do
this and in the future I'm going to know
to do this and I don't have to consult
the tool the second time because it
taught me a word that's great we teach
it words the words can get caught back
to other members of our society and then
they've got that knowledge and they can
move forward using the existing tools if
you look if you showed this to an
audiologist and audiologists could very
quickly give you or a musician an
engineer who's used to equalizers could
very quickly give you that effect
so I think in that there's going to be a
group of people that don't necessarily
want to understand the ins and outs of
the existing knobs we've got to win in
in terms of educating people who know
how to work it but maybe don't know what
you're talking about we've got to win
and we're never stopping you from using
the existing tool and let me say one
more thing about the existing tool let's
come back and look at it if I can ever
get to it now why does it look this way
can any of you guess why it looks this
way right there used to be hardware
there used to be hardware it was
constrained by the kinds of things we
could build in hardware knobs little
they didn't even have these readouts you
just had knobs with notches around it
you turn and so now when this software
first got going it went like this we
have professional engineers who have
learned to use the existing knob based
hardware you release a plug-in well back
in the day when these things first
started this piece of software would
cost five hundred dollars no amateur is
going to buy it only the professional
engineers are going to buy it so I
better give them an interface which is
exactly like the one that they already
know how to use because they don't want
to learn they've already they already
know what to do so what happens is all
sorts of design decisions that were made
because of the constraints imposed on us
by the hardware that we had available at
the time become calcified in this
software world where we can do anything
so I guess my last answer is we're
trying to think about well now that we
can do anything what should we do let's
try different kinds of interfaces ones
with words labeled on it or ones that
that our evaluation based where you just
say whether you like it or you don't
like it and we give you something why be
tied to this paradigm which was forced
upon us by constraints which no longer
exists so that's my other thought on
that
okay so should it sounds like we should
stop because there's food out there and
people okay yeah I'll be happy to talk
to you out there